[Música]
[Aplausos]
sos un caballo si me escucharon bien esa
es la pregunta que quiero que se hagan
durante esta charla sos un caballo
quiero que se la queden pensando porque
en el transcurso de esta charla manera
apareciendo posibles respuestas a esta
pregunta con lo cual se la repito una
vez más sos un caballo
faltan 417 días para el 2020
puede ser que digas bueno para ver no
llegamos todavía el 2019 ya estás
pensando en el 2020
sí porque el 2020 no va a ser como el
2019 el 2020 se avecina algo que es
completamente novedoso en la historia de
los seres humanos es es un momento clave
un momento crucial en nuestra historia
porque se avecina la cuarta revolución
industrial si la cuarta revolución
industrial y de lo que hagamos ahora en
este momento de nuestra vida va a hacer
la diferencia si va para nosotros va a
ser una revolución industrial o va a
significar una revolución del hombre
y de alguna manera puede que en este
momento te estés haciendo algunas
preguntas y lo cierto es que como toda
revolución va a traer consecuencias en
esta instancia las consecuencias van a
implicar cambios al nivel del del ser
humano a nivel de la forma de hacer las
cosas y al nivel del trabajo
quisiera reflejar algunos ejemplos para
que puedan seguir nos y piensen por
ejemplo hasta hace algún tiempo si
nosotros llamábamos a cualquier empresa
del otro lado nos atendía una persona
hoy por hoy hay que apretar varios
números en el celular para lograr
comunicarnos con un ser humano del otro
lado ese es tan sólo un ejemplo pensemos
en que en que pasa por ejemplo cuando
chateamos en un sitio web antes lo
hacíamos con un vendedor y hoy por hoy
lo hacemos con un chat bot que está
instalado en el sitio web de alguna
manera hay cambios que ya se empiezan a
percibir un ejemplo es que hace poco
sale una noticia en donde se establece
que los niños que han nacido en 2017 es
probable que nunca conduzcan un auto
este tipo de cosas son en las cuales los
invitamos a comenzar a reflexionar y de
alguna manera en el transcurso de esta
charla les vamos a decir qué es lo que
nos puede sacar airosos de esta cuarta
revolución industrial y eso que nos
puede sacar agregó sostengo dos noticias
para decirles la primera que es
es que todos nosotros lo tenemos la
segunda depende porque depende de si la
han desarrollado o no
me quedé pensando en el changuito que
estaba en el teléfono del otro lado y
digo que le habrá pasado porque al fin y
al cabo sí fue reemplazado por una
grabación que emula su voz y puede
atenderlo también como lo hacía el
digamos hasta qué punto hay ciertos
trabajos que siguen siendo necesarios
hasta el día de hoy y lo cierto es que
como estamos hablando de una cuarta
revolución industrial tenemos que estar
pensando también que mínimamente hubo
tres antes que ésta y en este sentido
queremos ser completamente sinceros con
ustedes porque
si lo pensamos bien para saber hacia
dónde vamos primero tenemos que saber
dónde estamos parados
y eso es lo que vamos a hablar en los
próximos minutos es decir los últimos
242 años de historia nos marcan la
manera en la cual nos tenemos que
enfrentar a esta revolución industrial
así que los invito a prestar atención
minuciosa a esto que va a venir ahora
porque va a ser interesante para todos
nosotros vayamos a la primera en 1769 se
crea la máquina de vapor
esto revoluciona la forma de transporte
en principio de transporte de mercancías
pero también de pasajeros por ejemplo
mediante la locomotora que aparece
aproximadamente en el año mil 776 la
locomotora viene a aliviarle el trabajo
a un animalito muy antiguo del ser
humano el caballo
ahora en 1880 86 aproximadamente aparece
este aparato que todos nosotros
conocemos muy bien y lo cierto es que si
la locomotora o la máquina va por lea
liviano el trabajo el caballo lo cierto
es que algo va a pasar con el caballo a
partir de este año si nosotros vamos por
ejemplo a 1903
nos vamos a encontrar con esta imagen y
allí arriba marcado se van a encontrar
con el único automóvil arriba a la d a
la izquierda el único automóvil en un
mundo tirado por tracción a sangre
pero esto no es todo porque si pasamos
en una sola diapositiva durante diez
años nos vamos a encontrar con esta
imagen esto es tan solo diez años
después es decir diez años después la
imagen se invierte
hay un solo caballo en un mundo de
automóviles básicamente si se alivianó
el trabajo el caballo y el caballo quedó
completamente desempleado
ya ha pasado en 1900
vayamos a la tercer revolución la
tercera tiene que ver con la generación
de 1970 y entre otras cosas tiene que
ver con la aparición de la computadora
pensemos en que trae sus orígenes en más
o menos 1936 aquella primera que se ve a
la izquierda ahí arriba es el desarrollo
de touring esto se desarrolla para
descifrar código enigma que era con que
en la máquina con la cual se transmitían
mensajes en la segunda guerra mundial de
alguna manera de ese antecesor trae un
conjunto de nuevas máquinas nueva
tecnología computadoras que le vienen
alivianar el trabajo y la vida a alguien
a quien al ser humano la tercera
revolución industrial no trae solo eso
trae algo más de alguna manera de forma
predictiva aparecen dos películas que
son claves para este proceso la primera
de ellas terminator 1984 una máquina que
tiene apariencia humana la segunda de
ellas en 1987
al revés una persona que tiene
componentes de máquina y nos vamos a
meter más de lleno en eso en breves
minutos
para comprender la cuarta revolución
industrial tenemos que pensar un poquito
en el pensamiento del renacimiento y
para esto seguramente ustedes conocen
esta imagen esta imagen está en la
capilla sixtina la pinta miguelángel
dicen que mientras pintaba la capilla
sixtina se fue quedando ciego bueno y
esta imagen lo que refleja es a dios
tocando al ser humano e insuflando le
aliento de vida en sus narices es el
momento en el cual dios le da vida al
hombre
sin embargo la cuarta revolución
industrial tiene algo muy parecido
lo que implica que es el hombre el que
ahora le va a dar vida a la máquina el
hombre es el que le está dando con su
aliento de vida su chispa de vida le
está dando vida
a la máquina donde nos vamos a encontrar
con cosas completamente insólitas hasta
este momento
quiero que recuerden las dos películas
que necesiten y quiero que vean lo que
les quiero mostrar ahora de la ficción a
la realidad 2018 terminator hacia arriba
en 1984 fíjense el ojo y de alguna
manera rose pensé esto es la realidad la
actualidad un director de cine que es un
cyborg él tiene una una filmadora en su
ojo derecho instalada que le permite
filmar hasta 4 horas de producción abajo
tenemos a robocop a la izquierda y a la
derecha tenemos a sofía ella es un robot
humanoide y es la primera en haber
alcanzado ciudadanía saudí
que quiero mostrar con esto al principio
les decía que va a traer grandes cambios
al nivel del ser humano y a nivel de
nuestra sociedad lo cierto es que si hoy
nos cuesta adaptarnos a las diferencias
humanas que nos va a pasar cuando la
vuelta de la esquina viva a un rose page
o tengamos a una sofía lo cierto es que
esto es inminente está realmente entre
nosotros
todos conocemos estos lobos por ejemplo
netflix le quito
a los fines el público quién de ustedes
hoy por hoy va a un videoclub a alquilar
películas buenos también letras les
quitó el trabajo a los videoclubs
pensemos por ejemplo en booking y cómo
empiezan hackear de una y otra forma las
agencias de turismo google le quitó el
trabajo completamente a las páginas
amarillas team der tender es una
aplicación para encontrar pareja que le
está quitando a mercado a los pubs y a
los boliches a donde antes se iba por el
mismo fin whatsapp está dejando casi
obsoleta a las compañías de telefonía
móvil y qué pasa con o lx están
utilizando de alguna forma los avisos
clasificados ya casi no es necesario ir
a conseguir un hotel porque con él bien
vi podés conseguir un departamento para
vos sólo uber de una u otra manera le
está quitando público a los taxistas y
por último las redes sociales están
haciendo que los medios de noticias y
los medios de comunicación empiecen a
quedar casi casi anticuados de alguna
manera todo esto nos hace notar como
mientras unos nacen otros mueren y ésta
seguiría álava en segunda variable que
trae consigo esta revolución nosotros al
principio les decíamos que empiecen a
reflexionar acerca de esta idea de si
soy o no soy un caballo y acá aparece
una pregunta con todo esto cuánto tiempo
crees realmente que va a durar tu
trabajo actual
verdaderamente pensás que puedes seguir
viviendo como viví hasta hace 10 o 20
años de alguna forma todo esto es lo que
nos invita a pensar y a replantearnos
algo que les dije al principio hay algo
que es esencialmente humano y es aquello
que nos da la posibilidad de salir
airosos de esta cuarta revolución y ese
algo es la creatividad brillando una
creatividad que desarrollamos hacia
afuera
tenemos bien ejercitado y nos sale muy
bien es una creatividad hacia adentro y
la capacidad de reinventarnos de
reencontrarnos con nosotros mismos de
destacar qué es eso que realmente nos
hace originales que nos hace únicos el
para qué estamos en este mundo que
vinimos a aportar y esto sólo se puede
encontrar a partir de procesos de real
auto exploración en personal esta
creatividad es la que nos va a sacar
airoso de este proceso y entonces acá me
toca decirles algo más y es el porque
somos dos en este escenario y ese porque
tiene un primer aspecto que tiene que
ver con que nosotros estamos convencidos
que la creatividad es un proceso que se
desarrolla mejor en comunidad que se
desarrolla mejor con otros cuando
tenemos un espejo del otro lado que nos
muestra otra versión y nos permite
florecer a aquello que somos realmente a
lo que se nos hace únicos distintivos y
no solamente
tiene que ver con la cuestión de
mirarnos en el espejo del otro también
tiene que ver con el hecho de que en la
vida la polaridad los opuestos es el
único la única entidad que forma un
completo que permite generar vida y eso
es lo que hacemos los seres humanos
combinarlos en esta polaridad para
generar algo nuevo algo distinto algo
mejor
al principio les decía que esta
revolución trae aparejados distintos
aspectos en principio nosotros decimos
más que hablar de una revolución de
industrial también podemos hablar de una
re evolución del ser humano en esta
línea hablamos primero de las cuestiones
vinculadas al ser a la sociedad hablamos
en segundo término de los cambios a
nivel de los emprendimientos y vamos a
meternos ahora a los cambios a nivel
laboral
hace muy poco rafael echeverría que es
un sociólogo y es uno de los máximos
expositores en lo que tiene que ver con
el coaching ontológico decía en una de
sus conferencias el coaching es la
profesión del futuro nosotros de alguna
manera seguimos con esta idea pero
decimos no solamente el coaching todas
las disciplinas que nos invitan a la
autoexploración las disciplinas que nos
invitan a sacar la mejor versión de
nosotros mismos en términos literales y
en esta línea
la pregunta es cuáles son las carreras
del futuro qué es lo que nos espera
pensemos primero que ocho de cada diez
jóvenes que hoy tienen entre 20 y 30
años van a estar empleados van a estar
trabajando en trabajos que todavía no
existen en segundo término pensemos en
qué pasa si mi trabajo actual lo puede
hacer una máquina si mi trabajo actual
lo puede hacer una máquina les voy
adelantando la respuesta está
comportándose como un caballo en segundo
término todo lo que tiene que ver con la
nueva producción va a ir quitando todos
los empleos que tengan que ver con la
mano de obra de forma literal y alguna
manera empiezan a aparecer estas
cuestiones todo lo que tiene que ver con
el manejo de las grandes bases de datos
o la big data lo que les mencionaba
antes como por ejemplo de psicoterapia
conciliación o el coaching algunos
aspectos de investigación científica las
ciencias del medio ambiente los
emprendimientos y el liderazgo y en
particular todo lo que tiene que ver con
las habilidades blandas pero centrémonos
dos minutos en la del medio
atención y cuidados de la salud está
previsto que aproximadamente para el
2025 tengamos el primer corazón impreso
en 3-d disponible para ser transplantado
en un ser humano
en el 2000 fines del 2017 en suiza ya se
produjo la primera tinta viva capaz de
reproducir tejido humano es decir
estamos metiéndonos en este mundo y de
alguna manera es hacer a dónde vamos y
es hacia allá a donde necesariamente
debemos empezar a acoplarnos a ese
cambio para verdaderamente estar
preparados para lo que se viene
todas estas profesiones necesitan un ser
humano que empiece a desarrollar un
conjunto de habilidades y competencias
completamente nuevas
por ejemplo la inteligencia emocional si
yo no desarrollo como individuo mi
capacidad de emocionar de emocionar
conmigo mismo de reconocer mis emociones
y reconocer las emociones del otro estoy
en un problema porque no me voy a
diferenciar de sofía
sofía puede reconocer las emociones pero
no puede sentir un robot puede
identificar qué tipo de emoción tiene un
ser humano pero no puede experimentar la
sutileza y la profundidad de la emoción
con lo cual la emocionalidad es un
aspecto profundamente humano que
necesitamos empezar a desarrollar y
desarrollar rápido también tenemos la
creatividad
el pensamiento crítico la capacidad de
poder tomar decisiones y hacernos
responsables de esas decisiones ahí
aparecía la idea de flexibilidad
cognitiva que es esto la flexibilidad
cognitiva lo que hace innecesario que yo
necesita ser reprogramado como pasa con
una computadora por ejemplo si vos
querés introducirle un programa y tu
computadora no está preparado para ese
programa lo que tenés que hacer es una y
tenés que bajarle otro archivo que lo
pueda actualizar los seres humanos no
los seres humanos tenemos flexibilidad
cognitiva pero la tenemos a veces tan
endurecida tampoco aceitada tampoco
aceitada que cuando aparece algo nuevo
nos cuesta aprenderlo y esto lo vamos a
desarrollar un poquito casi casi al
final
lo cierto es que ninguna de estas
habilidades se puede desarrollar sin
exploración personal
es decir sin un proceso de
autoconocimiento hace muchos años atrás
aproximadamente unos dos mil dos mil y
pico de años un templo en la costa de
delfos
ingresa en la grecia clásica y ese
templo tenía una inscripción tenía dos
una a la derecha y otra a la izquierda
la inscripción de la izquierda decía
conócete a ti mismo
es una premisa que tiene 2000 o más años
la pregunta es nosotros seres humanos
del siglo 21 cuánto nos conocemos
cómo puedo saber si tengo inteligencia
emocional
si no me exploro cómo puedo saber si soy
una persona creativa si no me exploro si
no lo averiguo si no me conozco si no sé
lo que soy capaz de hacer
es por eso y tan necesario el hecho de
que durante los últimos 2500 años todas
las tradiciones se han centrado en el
hecho de que el ser humano se
autoexploren no importa si hablamos de
sócrates platón aristóteles o de los
presocráticos no importa si hablamos de
las tribus indias o de alguna otra tivo
chamánica no importa todas apuntan a lo
mismo el hecho de que los seres humanos
tenemos que poder conocernos tenemos
porqué poder explorar nos a nosotros
mismos para saber quiénes somos es lo
único que nos va a diferenciar de un
robot del día de mañana de un programa
de un chat bot
porque es lo que se llama la capacidad
de mirarse al espejo y saber quién soy
vos te miras al espejo y sabes quién sos
pero qué pasa cuando te miras hacia
adentro
plotino
tiene una idea muy muy interesante
platino es un filósofo pasado ya el
siglo primero es un filósofo que aparece
casi dos o tres siglos después de cristo
y él decía algo muy interesante
ves sobre ti mismo
y mira
y si todavía no ves un bello rostro es
como el escultor el escultor dice el
cincel a se golpea golpea la roca saca
lo superfluo todo aquello que sobra
y no deja de golpear de pulir de lijar
de ilustrar hasta que no ve el rostro
que quiere ver en el mármol o en la
estatua
recién ahí está la estatua terminada si
nosotros nos empezamos a ver a nosotros
mismos como la estatua que somos como
piedras en bruto entonces nosotros
tenemos que empezar a dar cuenta que
debemos generar un proceso por el cual
empezamos a pulir nos empezamos a quitar
todo lo superfluo empezamos a quitar
todo aquello que sobra
toda esta conferencia versó sobre la
idea de que la cuarta revolución
industrial está muy cerca
y planteamos la pregunta de si sos o no
sos un caballo básicamente
con lo cual yo me pregunto
si te cuesta
aprender una aplicación nueva si te
cuesta empezar a convivir con las nuevas
tendencias de lo que somos los seres
humanos con la diversidad que somos los
seres humanos si nos cuesta
darnos cuenta de que el trabajo que
tenemos no es el trabajo con el que
vamos a terminar nuestra carrera laboral
si creemos que nuestra labor es para
toda la vida si creemos que las únicas
personas responsables son aquellas que
se criaron en los años 50 pero que las
personas responsables del día de hoy no
lo son porque no tienen los mismos
valores de responsabilidad que antes si
pensamos que los tiempos pasados fueron
mejores
muy posiblemente
estamos siendo equinos
y quizás en ese momento ya no va a haber
tiempo de venir con el caballo cansado
de alguna manera
no tenemos mucho tiempo faltan 417 días
ni un día más en este momento ni un día
menos tenemos que estar preparados va a
llegar el momento en el cual todo esto
que estamos viendo va a ser parte de
nuestra vida y va a estar a la vuelta de
la esquina no tenemos mucho tiempo el
momento es ahora es un momento de actuar
y de héctor rápido porque la revolución
industrial puede ser simplemente una
revolución industrial o puede ser la
revolución de los seres humanos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]